I'm a marionette I'm Arabic like I'm
from Morocco I'm allowed to be a second
year med student I have like some
trouble in my house like my parents are
fighting all the time and I'd like I
wish they'd divorce like they not
so like this making me a lot of science
woke up and starts crying and leave all
the stuff I wanted to be creative I went
to the other stuff but like a stuck and
this in this home and I don't have
anything to do what is your parents
fighting have to do with you not being
creative for example my my dad work of
course my mom also work so and I have a
lower brother I should stay at home all
the time though housework and at the
starting point I see this in two
different ways okay
why not whether you choose to accept
your circumstances or not
at what point you decide okay this is
not the life that I want to live and
you're gonna break out on your own and
deal with the consequences if that means
that you know your parents will talk to
you for a couple years like are you okay
with that or is it so important to you
that even after an honest conversation
saying like here's what I really wanted
a life and I have to go do this it's not
against you I just I need this in my
life that's option a option B is you
make the best of the situation that
you're in like one can be creative you
can do you have that you're doing it
right now like we're co-creating this
show together right here yeah you're in
Morocco I'm in Toronto we're making this
show we're helping entrepreneurs you can
create a lot like if creativity is your
gift then you find a creative way to
solve this problem right like that's all
you will get hit with is you have these
challenges in front of you you have to
use your creativity to solve them so
what's you have you have to be at home
and deal with your brother
how can you co-create together my dog
was on me while I was making the show
they come with me everywhere when I did
my workshop in May my dogs came when my
son comes with me he comes to the things
that I'm doing like I find a way to
co-create I see the same thing like
people ask about university should I go
to university I don't want to go to
university spent four years in
university well either you don't go to
university and you find your own path or
you go to university and you make it the
best possible experience for you like
you hack it you want to be an
entrepreneur while you're in university
then I did that make every course that
you go to about your your business every
marketing class you take you have a
project make the project about your
business you have to decide whether this
is the life that you want and that's a
personal decision like at what point do
you decide I'm gonna be an adult I don't
want to live what my parents want me to
live am I gonna break free and do my own
thing and and then deal with the
consequences and for as long as you
choose to accept those circumstances
then how can you make the best of the
experience that you have right now you
know if you chose even to keep your life
exactly the same way your parents who
work and you're gonna stay home and look
after your brother there's a million
ways to be creative from home and then
it's embracing all of those and trying
them right it doesn't have to be only
the only way to be creative is I need to
get out of the house and go meet people
right like you just met me this is great
yeah yeah right it's never been easier
to connect with people and to be
creative and to expose yourself to new
ideas as long as you accept the box and
you live inside the box as long I think
the only way to be creative is to get
out of this house then you've just
limited yourself which for a creative
person should be torture yeah so however
long you want to accept your situation
is up to you you know at what point like
if you're 30 years old are you still
gonna listen to your parents and be at
home looking after your brother or
whatever at some point you have to
decide I'm gonna live my version of my
life and maybe that's today and maybe
that's in next year or maybe you know
your brother's old enough in three years
and and you're okay
living the next three years this way
like how old are you now 19 years old
19 okay so you're you're an adult like
everything that happens from now on is
your fault as your responsibility yeah
you can't blame
parents anymore so if you spend the next
four years looking after your brother
it's because you chose to do so you
can't say you can't blame your parents
that you're 23 now and only now starting
to go out on your own because you spent
the last four years looking after your
brother you're choosing this life and
choosing to deal with the consequences
or lack of consequences now if you're
okay with it you know what like I'm okay
with it I want to support my family I
believe in that my parents work hard I
want this is a great chance to bond with
my brother cuz when we're older we won't
get that chance anymore and I'm okay not
pressing the gas full on for the next
four years well look after my brother
okay so then for those next four years
or however long what are you gonna do
then make the most of this opportunity
how can you be creative at home and find
a creative way to do that
instead of saying how can I be creative
at home you ask yourself how can I be
creative at home just a question but
just that just the intention a way right
yeah yeah just a belief that you can do
it so and again like maybe tomorrow you
go on and that's it and that's the end
and you're gonna leave home and then and
move to wherever come to Canada have
coffee together I do it right yeah maybe
that's tomorrow
but you could like if you wanted to you
could but there's consequences that you
have to deal with like sometimes I felt
like there's not enough money there's
not enough things to do like I want to
go to gym I want to travel I don't meet
new people work like I don't have money
this is oh there's lots of stuff like to
go to the gym you could you could work
out at home you don't have to go to a
gym or you can go to this public James
as outdoor gyms like there's survival
mode now getting passed to where you are
and then is building towards a better
life like could you get a job but an
industry that you want to learn if if if
moving to America was like your top
priority or top concern or come to
Canada because we're not yeah my friend
for example wanted to go to Japan so
badly you wanted to go to Japan and that
was his goal so he went to Japan and he
taught English in ship
you know he got some some low-level
entry job teaching English in Japan and
then worked his way up now he's doing
other stuff in Japan right not teaching
English anymore my sister wanted to go
to Africa so she went to Africa and had
no job and just started volunteering
somewhere and you know that volunteering
gave her just enough to room and board
kind of thing like hey here's a here's a
place for you to stay but wasn't making
any money and then she started providing
so much value that they wanted to hire
her and then that led to a different job
on a different job on a different job
and then she spent a decade in Africa
ultimately working for the United
Nations but starting off volunteering at
some organization I just would give her
enough to have a place to live at night
mm-hmm it's figuring out what is the
introduction opportunity for you if
getting out of the country is the most
important thing then there's lots of
things you can do to just survive like
is that the model for you do you want to
leave the country can you do enough
right now I think geographic location is
is becoming less and less important
I think there's tons of people from
Morocco who have one as an entrepreneur
I think to think that you have to come
to North America to win as an
entrepreneur is a losing mentality it
may ultimately be where you end up but I
think you can do a lot like you never
have all the resources that you need or
that you want there's always more even
now like I wish I had more like I wish I
have eight people my YouTube team if I
had 80 people I could do a lot more but
you have to do what you do with what you
have because nobody's gonna come and say
hey here's a million dollars go start
your business this part here is super
important like the struggle that you go
through is a very real situation like
having parents who fight haven't look
after their son your brother not not
being sure of what you want to do or how
to get out feeling trapped this is
something that a lot of people can
relate to and so by you going through
your journey of figuring it out you will
then be able to inspire and help a lot
of people who are in the same situation
every hero of every story has to go
through pain and struggle to get to the
other side to be the hero if you don't
have struggle and pain
never become a hero yeah what you
dealing with now is the best if you get
through it and even showing your journey
like if you if you create Instagram
content or YouTube videos saying I this
is what I'm trying to do I want to I
don't like my situation in life and so
I'm gonna try to fix it and here's my
join me on my journey to go through it
maybe 40 of the things that you tried
don't work but you showing your journey
one allows other people to have
confidence in themselves they go and do
it too because there's a lot of people
even in your home country of Morocco who
feel the exact same way but they're not
trying to get out of the situation
they're just unhappy they don't think
that there's a better path and so by
watching you do it they'll think huh
she's doing it maybe I can too it gives
you the sense of community and support
like I'm gonna try to do this I'm gonna
try to make a youtube video and you know
your first year do may suck but you have
people cheering you on to say hey keep
going - Congrats like your journey is
inspiring me more important than any
resources is your resourcefulness it's
fine in a way and if you have creativity
inside you that's that's the ultimate
power like that's all you need you just
gotta find creative solutions to figure
out your journey tip of the way this is
so inspire so but what are you gonna do
like inspiring is great right on yeah
but but what's the next step I was
thinking about starting like a YouTube
channel and inspire people because I'm
too like front of this inspiration and I
keep going like because of them like
they give me that much power to keep
going to study hard to let go I think
I'm gonna go into stars like in social
media like Instagram Facebook try to
figure out like both others people
problems like so I can figure out my
problems like that yeah so listen you're
getting a lot of love even in this
livestream people are giving you a lot
of love people relate to your story
I would pick one I wouldn't try to pick
Instagram YouTube and Facebook all
together cuz you'll end up like not
doing anything really well Instagram is
the easiest place to start
yeah YouTube is the is the better
long-term solution I think but Instagram
your easiest place to start
and I would just honestly tell your
store like don't try to answer questions
that you don't know the answer to just
tell your story just say here I'm a
woman from Morocco I'm 19 years old
I'm trying to figure out what I'm gonna
do with my life I know I don't want to
be where I am right now like if I am 40
years old living in the same situation
right now I know I'm gonna hate my life
and so I'm deciding that I'm gonna make
something better of my life and I want
you guys to join me in my journey and
then you go and you try stuff and you
experiment and you fail and and share
like if I'm you I would be making three
to five stories every day on Instagram a
morning message or what how you feeling
in the morning like guys it's Friday I'm
super excited ready to go start my day
or guys it's Friday I don't have energy
today I don't know why I'm trying to get
it cuz I'm trying to chase my dream but
I feel like I don't know I don't have a
lot of energy today but hopefully it's
gonna come like whatever you're actually
feeling don't try to be inspirational if
you're not inspired I think that's the
biggest mistake people make in making
this content they're speaking the truth
that is not their truth I was having a
conversation with an entrepreneur who
made a post on Instagram around his
morning routine is that guys morning
routine is so important you need to have
a morning routine it'll set you up for
the day and then I asked him what's your
morning routine okay I'm still trying to
figure mine and I don't know I'm not
it's not it's not good because I I slept
in too much it's like don't talk about
how important a morning routine is if
you don't have a good one yourself you
can say guys I'm really struggling with
my morning routine I don't know how I'm
gonna make it work but I'm over the next
three months I'm gonna try to nail down
a great morning routine and then take
people on the journey of what you're
trying to do a morning routine if you
went on to made a video talking about I
struggle every day because I have
parents who fight and I feel like I have
to look after my little brother and I
feel restricted and I want to change
that mindset I want to feel like I'm
unstoppable and so the next day months
I'm gonna go on this journey to find
ways for me to build them morning
routine to feel unstoppable that's way
better that's that's truthful that's
more truthful than guys to wake up you
got
these three things is gonna help you
yeah like that's what most people do but
it's it's not the truth because they
haven't done it themselves and so you
can only speak to what is true for you
and I think that's the fakeness that
people can spy that's why most people
don't end up popping and doing well
because they're talking about what they
aspire to be what they want to be
without being it and so don't do that
talk about your journey of becoming that
person and I think your story would be
really inspirational not just the people
from Morocco but almost everybody can
relate to the story that you're going
through right now
feeling like you don't have enough
resources of being in an environment
that is not supportive of you
you know achieving your dreams and then
you then deciding that this is not
acceptable and I'm raising a standard
for my life that becomes the difference
that becomes something that people want
to tag along if you want to know what
myself and other successful
entrepreneurs think about how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 250 for mornings I will
send you a video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long absolutely for free that as
you watch them it'll help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video